[Musique]
bonjour à tous nouvelle édition du 7 8
dossiers
nous vous proposons ce mois ci une
émission consacrée au mariage
plus de 230 milles 900 ont été célébrées
en 2015 budget moyen 15000 euros
dans notre série de reportages vous
allez découvrir les coulisses des
préparatifs de la location de la salle
jusqu'au choix des fleurs et pour
commencer nous vous proposons une
rencontre jacqueline et lucien viennent
de célébrer leurs 60 ans de mariage
un reportage signé camille lambert
il est beau grand chose un commentaire
là dessus soixante ans c'est par cette
photo d'aujourd'hui
jacqueline et lucien se sont rencontrés
en 1951
mais au début ce n'était pas forcément
gagné c'est un petit bal de quartier rue
des graviers à paris dans le 3e
arrondissement
et puis non non c'est toute la soirée
que ça sent les coups très bien soir je
la raconte pas il habitait rue du temps
donc c'était juste à côté si vous voulez
et moi mais bien élevé j'ai voulu faire
un bisou mais bon bisous c'est voler
elle n'a pas voulu gêner ou balpa pour
ville se bat pas pour chercher porter
comme on dit les gars est vraiment dans
sa bulle là pas trouvés
[Rires]
persévérant lucien tente à nouveau la
semaine suivante
et c'est le début d'une longue relation
ils se marient à paris le 16 mars 1957
la pause allait couper ce que je vous
dis là elle se rappelle de la nuit de
noces abazid avait à gérer en plus de
leur vie intime leur vie professionnelle
se fait-elle aussi main dans la main ils
exercent ensemble la profession de
charcutier leurs secrets la seule 7 cm
avec l'âge ça change des sentiments ils
sont toujours amoureusement si vous
voulez mais le plus autrui c'est de ne
pas pouvoir se passer l'un de l'autre
pour célébrer leur union le couple a
fêté en mars ses noces de diamant en
mairie de maurepas une cérémonie
émouvante
entourés de leurs enfants et même
arrière petits-enfants jacqueline et
lucien habite la ville depuis 1978
le maire leur a écrit un poème 60 ans de
main dans la main amoureux comme
également les bonheurs du quotidien
chasse
voyez cette belle image ça soit 50 ans
en arrière et voyez comme elle me
regarde je peux encore la regarder comme
ça où il est par des yeux mais je t'aime
mon coeur c'est vrai à 84 ans jacqueline
et lucien poursuivre leur route à 2
jusqu'à ce que la mort les sépare
j'ai noté qu'il n'y avait pas de piller
extérieur je ne sais pas si vous allez
en avoir besoin mais en tout cas il n'y
a pas de chaise pour l'extérieur
effectivement effectivement il n'ya pas
bien pas forcément pensé ça date de
réception organisation des menus
s'occuper de l'animation organiser son
mariage peut vite devenir un casse tête
pour éviter que le plus beau jour de sa
vie ne devienne un cauchemar ce client
installé à hong kong a décidé de s'en
remettre à anaïs et florence de wedding
planner
leur but réaliser votre rêve pas de plus
value c'est que on va s'occuper tout
niveau on est très sereins il y aura
moins de stress parce que forcément il
n'a toujours un petit peu pour un
mariage c'est normal mais voilà on va
être là pour les accompagner et les
aider au maximum et surtout ça soit la
décoration le traiteur la salle de
réception un photographe
on s'occupe de tout
voilà un an et demi qu'elle ont ouvert
leurs agences anaïs et florence située à
trappes
les deux organisatrices s'adapte à votre
demande selon la thématique est le lieu
[Musique]
le budget moyen d'un mariage avec son
invité et d'environ 15000 euros
les wedding planner ont de nombreux
partenariats avec des salles de
réception encore des photographes en
faisant appel à elle vous fait environ
15% d'économies sur votre budget on est
là aussi justement pour négocier les
prix avec les prestataires ce que les
particuliers ne n'osent pas ou ne
demande pas forcément donc nous avec
avec nos partenariats du coup on peut
justement essayer de de répondre à leurs
critères en rentrant dans leur budget et
c'est ce qui est assez compliqué de
faire quand on n'a pas de zink à l'heure
anaïs et florence prépare déjà des
mariages pour la saison 2010 8 pour
berlin organisé l'événement il faut s'y
prendre au moins un an à l'avancé
dans un mariage il n'y a pas que les
bulles de champagne qui peuvent faire
tourner la tête le prix aussi la
priorité numéro une pour les mariés
sélectionner le lieu dans les yvelines
un business s'est développé celui des
salles de prestige on retrouve des
dizaines de dieu à des prix pouvant
aller de 5000 à 20000 euros pour une
soirée l'un des plus connus l'abbaye des
vaux de cernay un domaine cisterciens
construire xiième siècle pour se payer
cette part d'histoire il faut faire
chauffer la carte bleue
une centaine d'individus il faut compter
un ticket moyen
si je peux parler ainsi en termes
hôtelier a minima aux alentours d'une
centaine d'euros pouvoir aller jusqu'à
150 euros à 150 euros par personne bon
nombre de jeunes mariés se sacrifie pour
pouvoir s'offrir l'abbaye des vaux de
cernay
c'est un événement unique dans leur vie
donc ils savent aussi faire la part des
choses parfois même emprunté lourdement
pour se faire plaisir à l'abbaye
l'abbaye accueille aujourd'hui entre 50
et 70 mariages chaque année certains
clients n'hésitent pas à parcourir des
milliers de kilomètres pour venir fêter
le plus beau jour de leur vie
le bouche à oreille fonctionne très bien
m'a beaucoup de mariages américain
beaucoup de mariages libanais la
communauté libanaise a mis le pied à
l'abbaye il ya quelques années on les
mariages généralement très somptueux qui
s'étendent généralement sur deux voire
trois jours
autre élément incontournable d'un
mariage les fleurs dans le département
les mariés et leurs familles peuvent
dépenser entre 500 et 1500 euros pour se
faire une place sur ce marché ultra
concurrentiel ce fleuriste implantée à
villepreux n'hésite pas à suivre les
dernières tendances
ces derniers temps surtout vous n'avez
vraiment beaucoup de choses qui se sont
mis en place dans la décoration on est
vraiment sur une mode qui est sûre du
champêtre
une mode qui est sûre du naturel du
romantique les mariés sont vraiment
friand de petites décorations de détails
un souci du détail qui a un prix 1000
euros pour un panier moyen dans cet
établissement
un coût qui s'explique en grande partie
par le temps qu'il faut pour réaliser le
bouquet parfait 10 à 15 minutes en
moyenne et surtout trouver les idées qui
feront la différence le jour j un
bouquet réussi dans un mariage c'est une
excellente associations de couleurs avec
un très beau camaïeu de couleurs des
couleurs qui s'associe très bien
et après le choix des fleurs le choix
des fleurs est important parce que ça va
apporter ça va apporter le le relief la
forme
une fois les fleurs sélectionner les
mariés devront également ajouter les
traditionnels faire part à la robe de
mariée les animations au total le budget
de cette journée grains peut rapidement
pour atteindre les 15000 euros en
moyenne pour cent convives sûrement le
jour le plus heureux mais aussi le plus
coûteux de leur vie
[Musique]
c'est l'objectif de chaque mariée mettre
les petits plats dans les grands
une spécialité pour ce traiteur de
montigny le bretonneux cocktail lui
pièce entrée et plat et buffet de
desserts tous a réalisé avec des
produits locaux alors en pièces cocktail
par exemple on va travailler sur une
pièce kfc féminine
c'est une une brochette de une pince de
radis noir avec une crevette marine à la
menthe
c'est très fred légèrement croquants
très féminin nous avons également un
ceviche de saumon aux pertes de news où
nous avons un rôle important dans une
réception de mariage
de par la qualité de la prestation au
niveau du service l'amabilité des gens
être à l'écouté des clients être le plus
discret possible et également au niveau
de l'art culinaire et de l'art de la
table
il faut que nous soyons à la hauteur des
attentes des clients et pour conclure le
festin des mariés place à la pièce
montée une tradition né au xviiie siècle
est toujours d'actualité pour un coût
qui oscille entre 400 et 1000 euros
une activité symbolique pour ce
pâtissier la pièce montée c'est ce que
ça représente pour un mariage va sceller
fait ou est ce que les gens aiment
vraiment le bouquet final du mariage le
dessert qui étant attendues après avoir
réalisé les choux c'est le moment de les
garnir avec une crème pâtissière un peu
particulière en fait on utilise de la
vanille bourbon
car plus qu'à un goy très aromatique car
un goût très particulier pour la crème
pâtissière et qui la différencie d'eux
ne clame pas de cirque classique avec
une poche à douille
donc je vais encore ma poche de crème
pâtissière et après je vais percer juste
le dessous du chou et je veux venir
remplir de laon pour glacer les choux
damien utilise un caramel à base de
glucose une technique pour travailler
plus facilement le caramel donc là
maintenant je passais au montage donc je
récupère un petit show je viens lui trop
lu glace et le
le côté dans le caramel je reviens et je
le déposer délicatement sur manu gâtine
plus on grimpe plus le montage devient
délicat pour décorer cette montagne de
chou damien utilise du sucre tiré pour
fabriquer des rubans vient ensuite la
touche finale avant de pouvoir faire
craquer les invités
merci de nous avoir suivis vous pouvez
retrouver en replay cette émission sur
le site internet ou sur notre
application mobile tv fil 78
on se retrouve le mois prochain pour une
nouvelle édition du 7 8 dossiers
[Musique]